e
good afternoon Mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record uh State
Treasurer Monica
mapelli so I just um share with you uh
what I've been working on um it it is
essentially uh a proposal to do a
housekeeping housekeeping um this next
uh legislative session to do some clean
up of the accounts that we currently
hold um I have custody of and others
that no are listed in the law but they
don't know they I don't we no longer
have those accounts so um so it's an
attempt to to take to to clean that up
um the the other piece is this this
those so so those accounts that I'm
primarily um referring to and I added
pages so uh the other thing I did is I
highlighted everything so so we don't
get lost on what what I ended up um uh
adjusting or or or for discussion
purposes but um essentially what the
work that I'm that I'm that I'm doing is
on pages uh uh for uh let's see is 15
and um 16 which are the what is called
the custodial ancra accounts and the
trust and what they used to be referred
as agency funds so uh that's the the the
primary goal here to to clean up those
accounts those accounts they used to be
referred as um again trust and agency
funds that terminology changed with a
new accounting standard back in
2020 um the act for now refers to those
agency funds as custodial accounts the
war agency was removed from the
literature essentially because it was
confusing readers uh so they decided to
eliminate that concept so we do have uh
a definition in this
section um for an agency fund so that's
another thing that um this this proposal
considers removing the word agency and
the definition instead of um again we
will remove could will remove the
definition of agency and now we call
them custodial accounts which is
anything that the state holds that is
not State's money
absolutely behind trying to write and
and listen at the same time yes I don't
see anything that says custodial funds
in here it's just saying per trust
permanent and endowment
funds that that's correct uh represent
so that's
um RSA
612c yeah uh considers
trust and I'm suggesting to add the word
permanent which is what we we refer to
some funds some trust that maintain we
maintain the Corpus only and then the
word endowment because before it wasn't
included so but then the other section
is RSS
62d those
include um oh custodial and escar
accounts okay so the work so the work
that you'll see once you have an
opportunity to review is
essentially
um first of all what it's trying to do
is include all of the accounts that is
not general fund include them in the
list R say 12 uh 612
612b 612 C and 612 D so they're either
a a typical dedicated
account a trust or a custodial
account
um there is a section in
[Music]
um it's actually I say 612e that talks
about if agencies
have a new dedicated fund is a trust or
custodial account essentially they can
come to the treasure for a possibility
of having a that account separately
maintained so we could per perhaps open
up and we do for for those trusts and
and C accounts we do have separate bank
accounts but one of the things that we
want to distinguish is what is
considered a typical educated fund for
example last time we were talking about
the can Mountain fund that's just a
typical dedicated fund so we wouldn't
have a separate bank account for that
but we would and we do for the venam and
thumbon Trust for example so so I guess
what this cleanup does is it puts the
trust and C accounts that we currently
have and have separate bank accounts
under RSA 612 CN but anything else goes
back to a typical dedicated account
612 could could I ask I can't find 9 612
b or
a have they just disappeared or no no
the is here is just it's just um let me
locate that the beginning of all the
numbers so R6
oh a a is shall establish and maintain
accounts and B is money received by the
state treasurer shall be accounted for
General except that b includes the
Lottery Commission remove that actually
fines a whole bunch of when does B end
is B what we've always thought of as the
612s
it is um what page are you I'm on page
one and two I can double check this but
it is possible
removed all right so
so a and
the so 612 A and
B it it is an oh is Page One
in 12b just speaks about monies received
by the state treasurer as Pro 6
611 shall be accounted for in the state
accting system 612
Dash yeah it is possible I did not
include B in here I don't know um no
there is a b right under a on on that
one and then we start with all of the
right is it's not relevant to the
is in that that fund is actually one
that we keep we have a separate bank
account for that is is the electric
assistant program so that that statute
pertains to to that deer account it is
possible I I missed it so I can redo
this but so I'm not there not any
changes on that one but it will be part
of the universe essentially that account
yeah she just didn't print those two
that's yeah it is possible that I missed
that
um okay but that's really what it is you
four so so um the yellow
highlights I just for example 71 I just
was just highlighting the fact that
um that's the 612b so it's I wanted to
highlight the fact that in in the list
of dedicated
accounts it is already consider the fact
that six RSI 612b is in your list and
there's another section and I don't want
to skip around too much but
um on page six so it shows item 167 and
6 168 you
have the funds persuant or 6612 C and D
those are listed under a typical
dedicate account so it's just to to
highlight that piece but um going back
to page
four item
7A um I'm REM I'm proposing to remove
that because I'm putting it under
the trust accounts so right now it's
listed Us in the typical lady accounts
but I'm moving it to the trust section
this 71 or it 78
78 okay next highl yeah correct so
essentially what she's saying is trust
funds are different yeah than all these
other dedicated funds and therefore
they're going to be in their own section
not in 612 and that's following the what
the current structure I think that's
that's how it was at some point the law
was written that way it just got messy
over the years because he wasn't kept up
so my goal is to make sure that you know
going forward once we're able to do this
initial
housekeeping will'll review on a regular
basis to ensure that you have the
there and so essentially most of these
yellow cross out things are trust funds
correct so you're going to see them in
the section for trust funds got and I
only put one back the there's one for
the list of dedicated accounts there's
only one that we put under the dedic
dedicated fund list which
is so a couple I guess uh the Water
Resources project when you read that law
it just looks like a typical dedicated
account it doesn't look like there's
really anything in particular why I
should hold that separate and then the
drinking water groundwater trust fund
that has its own section but it was
never added to the to the list to the
universe represent a moment yeah
why what does it do to have
71 just to start with the beginning of
it in as a dedicated fund when
what is 12b that it's referring to so
12b is that is is the the tutor
reference um Jennifer was was uh reading
before that is one of the accounts that
we hold as the electric um assistance
program so it's just listed here in
addition to where it was the enabling
statute the the the creation of that
fund well that that should be a
dedicated fund as far as I'm conc but so
you should you need the title electric
something or other yeah under 71 just
like all these others have a name right
they don't just say well a fair number
of them don't have names and it makes it
very difficult we could we could add
that the actual the actual law if you if
you again I'm sorry it's not here but
when you read 612b it doesn't it doesn't
mention the electric assistance program
fund but that's the but that's what it
is but we can add we can add it
name
yeah and a name that allows you to go
find the law if you want it correct it
took me a while to fund that account
actually just because it didn't have a
name but that's in essence what this is
doing and again it's just cleaning up
moving the trust accounts under the
trust section and anything that is looks
like and sounds like an escrow or a
custodial is move is is moving that to
the custodial account and what this will
allow us to do is it's also a guide not
only for for the committee and
legislators but also for agencies
because sometimes they want they come
and say well we would like a separate
bank account so this will really um kind
of provide that criteria like if it's
not if this account is not under a trust
or a Custer account then I really need a
good reason why I will need to open a
separate bank account for that question
represent W is a trust fund funded other
than out of the general fund like have
separate income whereas most of the
other ones that are dedicated funds are
coming out of general fund generally
maybe maybe Highway fund or some other
fund but that that's in Ence what it is
so trust funds were either created is
not stay they're not State funds they're
just perhaps initially some of them were
funded with a particular some's name is
on them somebody gave us a $100,000 or a
million dollars correct and so that so
that typically we keep
again dependent on what it is but Mo
most of the time we keep those in a
separate investment account and those
grow differently and it's just we don't
add money to them in the general fund it
just Grows Right for the most part yes
there's some that allow gifts and
donations by other entities and when
that happens we need to keep an eye on
those because all of a sudden it's not
public money I mean it's it's just a
different type of account that we need
to keep an eye on is there a
significance between difference between
the word endowment and trust or
not um no but we have all kinds of
flavors so I just wanted to make sure
that we were including both I mean the
endowments typically the there there may
be some trust that there if if we some
if some funds were umed to the state
then perhaps the entire amount can be
spent but most of the times the
endowments you you you need to keep the
initial amount
permanently and and just use the income
so that sometimes comes into play when
it comes to an endowment
fund let me ask turn to page
on yes so these three Connecticut Lakes
funds are ones we've been talking about
this
year um why are you moving them because
they're endowments because they're
they're end right and we already have
separate investment accounts for those
so they're they're fall under the type
of accounts that we are maintaining
separately is the act of moving These
funds to the other list going to take
them away from the perview of this
committee no no no unless they have un
accept sounds like I was speaking with
uh um with the controller and it sounds
like there's some exceptions um when it
comes to reporting un as you add them to
the list of exceptions and know then all
of these accounts should be reported to
you for the most part all of these
accounts the endowments and the trust
those are on the those are we have
custody of them so we will come and
report to you on a regular
basis represent M yeah well first the
ones that we decided to remove are ones
that are reported directly every year to
some agency and the public get to see
the
reports and and they objected to having
to do two different kinds of reporting I
see but second what I wasn't caught up
with what you were doing when you
started uh 167 and 168 what's the
purpose of having these
in
B so
1B or whatever it is right so 167 168
um those references have been there the
entire time it just sounded like the the
enabling legislation want wanted
everything listed under RSA
612 uh whether that's needed that's up
to this committee and and legislator
seems me that it's needed but not there
in this list of all the dedicated funds
that it ought to be up near the top
somewhere as part of the
system and it could be maybe that's how
all of the accounts were initially
um that's a good point those could be
removed well I I think it's probably a
good idea to have them there so that
that shows that we have some kind of say
over it I think but but putting them up
at the beginning before the list starts
they're all the things in C and all the
things in D yeah okay we're never going
to be able to get rid of the repeals are
we you probably never want to reuse the
number yeah yeah well we got rid of a
whole bunch of stuff when we started
this system it was an alphabetical
system they were down to things like
13 that the next
is so these are the two most
recent Water Resources project well I I
added those so so the Water Resources
was listed under the trust and it's not
a trust the drinking water groundwater
trust fund I'm not sure you're being
reported on that because it wasn't in
the
list it was it is again yeah it is an
RSA
6D one but it wasn't anywhere in the
section of the law so I'm not sure
you're being reported on that so why
isn't that in the groups of trust
f
um that's a great
question um so the group of trust funds
that
we have and or that amadden to the RSA
612 D and
um so I I guess what I would say is
according to uh financial reporting
purposes the controller has always kept
that fund under the general
fund I do not fully understand the
specifics but that that's how it's seen
uh we do maintain a separate Bank
separate investment account for that one
um it
is it in my opinion we we could put it
under the list of trust funds if you if
you want it um but that's the only
reason because it's not considered a
feary fund according to um this one
fund my SE it with that account is it it
provides loans it it is
um it is similar to the Clean Water
groundwater um fund it provides loans to
municipalities so they use it um it's
another source of funds is but it's
similar is used in a similar way as um
it's a revolving fund as a revolving
fund correct yeah and so I think it's
and probably originally done by the
legislature right correct cuz that was
that was a settlement money and then
that fund was created and now it's being
used sort of like as part of regular
business instead of trust would be a
better
typ okay whener when we work on the fish
and game budget my recollection is they
have as many as 13 dedicated funds they
have uh sub dedicated oh some for bait
some for
uh they coaching some for something else
and so are those part of these funds so
those likely are listed in the first
section where all of the the loan
list uh we don't have separate accounts
for those those are definitely they
should be part of game department the
loan list of funds so they would would
they be under fishing game rather than
we probably under the dedicated funds
because they have control of them and
they use them at various times right my
my what I will
my guess is that they're going to be
somewhere in the list one through 300
one through what is the last one so
here's fishing game in the book right so
they're
um page 258 and so
on they are somewhere between 1 and 396
or
394 well two of those number two and
number three in in 612b one
b 2 58 we
found
right they must be the the
oldest
yeah well no no
they that when they did a
numeric they I don't know I don't know
how they change the order yeah fines and
damages license plate fund Statewide
Public boat access search and rescue so
they're all in
there so they're all there that search
and rescue I'm delighted that was a
10year project to create that Pike
safety card all sorts of resistance and
now it brings in 300,000 a year when
they used to come and ask us for 100,000
every year because Senator Ros search
and rescue was behind
on page um
12 number
360 the opioid abatement trust fund I'm
wondering if that should be moved to the
trust fund section because those are
funds that we really can't spend in any
other way except how this Department of
Justice
so the way even though so the way this
fund has been treated it has been
treated as a typical dedicated
fund
um it it really is a legislative
decision if
if we don't have a separate investment
account do we have a
separate I don't think we couldn't in
house bill to would say we're going to
take all the money out of the H be right
to Pap and trust
fund which we could do in some of these
other funds if we did that with this we
would violate the terms of the
settlement and we would lose all that
money so I'm just wondering if it should
yeah that that would be move under the
trust it is it is so so I think it is is
it will be fine I think some of the some
of the difficult sometimes it's
difficult to really understand the the
legislative intent um because we see
trust created all the time so then as we
have to figure it out is it really a
trust do they really intend to maintain
it as a trust and a lot of times when
you read the language it sounds and
feels like a typical fund so but but
based on what you're saying I think if
it's moved to the trust section it is
probably a it is a better it will be a
better understanding of all of us at
trying to figure things out
you know the type of account that that
the um the intent of legislature will
create in that account or that in this
case the trust so I think it will be
fine thank you you're
welcome so I could could provide that
change if you we like that I just
scanned down this one page and there is
a
fmli premium stabilization trust fund in
375 Maybe maybe we
could could get this list of trust funds
in front of the com controler also and
get her to weigh in on this yeah that is
funny and she and and uh um she's I
shared my list with her she's reviewing
it she U she just couldn't provide me
with comments but she she will Pro
probably have some comments trust and
you will see a lot of trust then and but
we don't consider those trust yeah but
but but again that's been difficult for
all of us who are trying to take care of
those funds whether it is really a trust
or it was just the war trust used while
creating those funds would we have the
power to change the name of the ones
that are not
confusion and then move the trust the
first we'd have to Define what a trust
fund is so what what definition would
you definition is here already it was it
has been
there um that is on page
14 that's the letter G oh no that's
F
14 yeah page 14 letter F letter F you
have that definition there trust fund
it doesn't really address the issue um
of the opioid opioid trust fund which
had well had a lot of deceased people
but they weren't
involved so a lot of times says usually
yeah it does say usually so a lot of
times when
um so TR SEC Creator in
law but but there is no trust document
created so for example um I'm
gonna the
um nuclear the commissioning fund that
has a trust there is a trust document
associated with the fund so that's an
easy one that's a trust but a lot of
times this this the the the L here
doesn't have a document that goes with
there or any type
of of is so that's why doesn't it some
sometimes it's just a name and not an
actual trust especially the way the law
is written and the way those funds are
used so um it would be great if we if if
if the legislature creates trust um
creating a trust document to go with it
could be sort of like a secondary fece
that way in the future um there is no
desire to change legislation all of a
trust yeah so thank you for that page it
it obviously identifies both the trust
trustee and the
custodian so yeah trustee is needs a
trustee a trust account needs a trustee
correct and it's going to be someone
likely outside the government whereas
the custodial accounts likely going to
be the government probably you correct
and I'm I'm actually Trustee of some
accounts um like the for example the
fight plan I'm the trustee of that
there's a trust document associated with
that it's not here because we don't it's
it's people's money but but that's one
example of a document and I'm the
trustee of of of that program so can you
and the comproller get together and
review everything that has the name
trust and and uh make a recommendation
if they're not really trust and then we
can come up with new names for
them okay I think she will because but
uh from financial report and
purposes U she will probably suggest to
remove the war trust from so many of
these funds but again it will be up to
the legislature to Define what it is
that you really if any of those funds
are are really trust according to the
legislative intent like the I guess what
I'm asking is yes for you to anything
that has the word trust in its title but
does not meet the definition in
F right to highlight that for us okay
and then we can take the action of
removing the word
trust okay absolutely trust should also
announce who is the
trustee and what if the trustee
dies and should well the state would be
the trusty right no no in many of them
it names a person trust usually could
name a person or it should be The Heirs
of and so whoever goes next in line if
someone dies but if if if it's a trusted
and so usually she's the um she has the
uh administrator administrator of many
of these but may not be the TR the
trustee if it I am the truste and many
in the law states law shall be the
treasur of the State of New Hampshire
that pretty obvious and we don't have to
worry about any successors yeah but if
it's the trust names a person they
should be within the the
text or or The Heirs of so it's it's
pretty clear because the trustee has the
responsibility to invest the
funds not putting it all on her so you
know and that's why she's there I know
but if if they if they don't name her as
the trustee specifically yeah if someone
names their family to be the and wants
to keep their name on it forever but
then why would we have the money
yeah because it's it's for some
government purpose oh I see well so I'm
leaving I'm leaving my keep the person's
name on it I see what you're saying the
one I read recently in a fiscal item
that somebody left uh a shoreline 12
acres was it the U Glen's something
Glen's Glen Cove Glen Cove and uh so it
was a life estate until he died of
course nobody maintained it while he was
elderly and and still using it so now
they're spending a lot of money to get a
a consultant to decide which buildings
need to be torn down which ones need to
be fixed and how much it's going to cost
this is going to take a couple of years
before it finally becomes part of the
state park so in that instance obviously
he didn't leave a family as trust gave
it to fishing game with a life estate so
every every one of these has a little
bit trickier different way it's left
some will be left her as the trustee
some will be left with family as
trustees some will be left as life of
State all these different
mechanisms I remember
that Mr chair yes representative Jan
thank you um just a general question um
where do these definitions come from is
this in the rsas or yes this is this is
ex law um okay again the only the only
that's why I highlight everything else
to find it but everything else is exist
is is is the current law because I guess
when I read trust and it says means in
that first line usually with a formal
written agreement contractor will of
deceased person and I just I think about
there's a lot of trusts out there where
the trustee is a living person and
created it so I'm I guess I'm not sure
why it's deceased I mean it could be
deceased or non deceased right you're
misreading it so okay formal written
agreement comma contract comma or will
of a deceased person oh you see what I
good point okay yeah that works all
right now it makes
sense all right all right so do you you
have something to do we El set any
questions about thank you very much for
concerning this um so I will work with
um uh controller call to to identify the
trust I'll highlight it for you and I
can come back next time you meet I'm
guessing we're generally in favor of
making these changes yes I would follow
her recommendations and would file a
bill if we I don't want to go beyond the
filing period without at least filing it
by name then maybe having to amend it
January of February whenever he up so
this is this is a
more I I wouldn't want to necessarily
bury this in our other committee bill
right yeah make a separate bill out of
this yeah yeah so it's clear and I'm not
sure what commed it would go before
probably Edna yeah right but
um I had one more question some of these
anything no no everything the name from
one place to another no we're not
repealing anything and bringing more
government money back into the
government that would be my point from
all of this exercise do we recover any
money from dedicated funds to General
funds no okay but but but actually I
just want to clarify the the only ones
are being
repealed are because we no longer have
those funds there's zero funds in them
so we don't gain anything when correct
no no you don't have extra money
unfortunately but uh um there some of
the ones that I'm repealing like for
example there's one called the
disolution of cor Corporation account of
the state treasurer that doesn't exist
um uh there was another
one the racing and charal gaming escra
account that doesn't
exist yeah so we're we're repealing
those totally under under this proposal
just because they don't
and there's another the Caroline a fox
fund that doesn't exist um the
department gets income from the actual
trust but there is no such thing as the
we don't have the trust
ourselves it's in Department of Ed that
is um that is the Caroline a fox fund
that is part of the Department of
cultural and um natural
resources not managed through your
office
yes inde no I think what what was
happening and I was asking about this
particular account we used to receive
the income from the trust and I believe
that is um somewhere in Massachusetts we
get the income and we were depositing
that that those amounts into a separate
investment account but the beneficiary
is the department so now the money is
being sent directly to the department it
doesn't come to our office there's
really no need to for us to be
intermediaries so they receive the money
and they use it for um you have you have
to keep it on your books is is um so not
not separate books it's just part of the
uh Department's books the money that
they get to fund that program still
you're the
fiduciary yeah represent M yeah I was
just this the state of Massachusetts
fine with
that because it's a Massachusetts
organization which is say ending the
money for the maintenance of this
forestry group I believe so I mean I I
have not even seen that document I can't
I can do additional research on this but
my understanding is we no longer have
anything at the
treasury
um it's just going straight to them it's
the the the income the it's going
straight to the finish uh the
beneficiary which is the department but
I can ask I about that our departments
allowed to do this
to to be
accepting well yeah donations yeah they
do from everywhere they ask ask the
fiscal committee to approve you know
when somebody wants to give money the
fiscal committee can approve it yeah
okay could could I often there's strings
attached right so yeah anyways yes
represent there was this drinking water
ground drinking water groundwater trust
fund on page p which is on page 13 that
we sort of started discussing but I
think we turned off onto something else
this is one apparently should have been
in 612 and they discovered it that it
wasn't correct it's just being added to
the to the list to the
universe didn't put it in 612 for some
but this brings back your question about
whether we should have a trust if this
should be a trust or not so yeah right
that's a trust f question I'll I'll
that thanks thanks very much for your
time no thank you very much bu okay oh
yeah always represent so what what kind
of opportunity do we have to meet again
about this or do we do it all as
IOP I was hoping that this would be our
penultimate meeting
oh okay is that I was thinking of it as
the ultimate as the ultimate meeting
okay no penultimate got it second to
last yeah yeah the last one was the
too um because we still
have well we still have the the um final
report I mean if you think we can do
enough to you know charge me with
writing it or making changes to it or
whatever I think we probably should have
another meeting but okay all right maybe
one more next we come in thinking that
okay well next week isn't time enough
for them to do their work
oh well there's not too many weeks left
yeah remember that committee amendments
or committee
bills uh usually go to rules and rules
just passes them on through
so that's you know there's not a not a
worry later you know so and we're going
to have a five
we you are I think so
election well I mean if you want the
last meeting could be the 30th for
example that's two
weeks from to
anyway all right so let's just remember
the further that you get into this month
the harder it is uh for people who are
running for election re-election to
commit because things will come up very
quickly and will preempt you yeah okay
you mean you some of you have opponents
is
[Laughter]
that okay okay not much of one but
oh all right so now we want to look at
the the um the report okay and uh we
have three documents to kind of to kind
with
e